welcome to this video playing la Brits
labyrinth from Belarus okay the Smith
Maura yeah should I take it I don't I
don't really want to let's just play an
irregular c3 Sicilian probably more
advisable I don't know them it ends it
out of this ms Maura really okay ya hear
what oh I can also take yes mmm Bishop
c4 is the most come and move okay this
is definitely very much play above a
wide 93 probably now not to write sure
how I should develop here can I afford
to play actively here with the g6 some
look like that time do I need to be with
more modest with e6 i think i can go g6
Bishop c4 Knight b6 should be okay
I should be quick enough with with
castling I can also wait I can also
maybe play hmm there should be six maybe
intending night takes you three but okay
this this [ __ ] just shouldn't be bad
really there should be three Bishop g7 I
should be okay I don't think that this
should be any any big problem nice
taking some time I mean Bishop b3 looks
looks fairly falsehood okay I guess
let's let's castle here until now Bishop
g4 is the the most obvious continuation
I might just play age three but i can
probably take and even take with the
dish of on deform just be materialistic
now yeah this is a good good news
probably setting up this pin with the
bishop on b3 the bishop won't be three
is active but it's not helping to break
the pin here on g41 so it's not so easy
if I am now to deal with this pressure
on now on the default power D 595 is
definitely fine for me
yeah maybe something like this okay I'm
27 does not make much sense probably
just bank I can play Knight c5 maybe
activating this piece attacking b7 em
yeah that's possible
I mean he definitely has to reckon with
me taking on taking on default I think
might see if life should be probably
tried not sure how I how I play then I
mean I can always take on f3t to take on
deform and the tea will get b7 back so
that's not not a very very convincing
but how do i kappa b 78 all night a 5
and 97 something like that maybe okay
exchanging this Bishop is also not not a
bad thing and I prepare 97 get rid of
the the 90 m maybe they also was some
some combination of of Knight f3 Bishop
e3 and taking but this looks I look
simple and okay for black I hope yeah
this is maybe maybe the same
I can take on b3 maybe first a B and
even back to c 8 yeah this is this is
not bad actually I mean cakes yeah now I
can even think of completely retreating
to see eight then 95 and b6 next yeah
this is just good for black it takes
time but I keep the two bishops and I
have the knight on d5 then be sick there
this is excellent for black well and his
play even slower than I am yeah that's
the somewhat dragged back the only
chance he needs to activate but okay put
it here and next is b6 maybe he can play
queen of three so that after b6 knight
c6 as possible but we never does not do
it b6 knight c6 Quincy 7s just ok for me
so I can can play that here
and now I have this is nicer the bishop
here also is feared she toad and today I
can get rid of this but it's still very
very convenient for black let's see how
do I continue clean to d5 would be nice
actually here at night to e6 screen to
d5 yeah this is chris is good and Knight
g4 but I have 25 I can take just a check
on age 6 okay hmm
Andrew where that that's that's not bad
ok I probably have to exchange this
thing the night on therefore I mean ok
what now just take d for maybe can go to
c7 I can then also just take be too if i
want yeah should be ok
rook c8 he could have taken taken a
seven I don't want want that really okay
should I just take be two or is this too
greedy and I take it I'll take that okay
yeah now it's not even threatening
something as the rukia's hanging time
morning so maybe I can can just play
look see ATM and our thread stuff off
check
Jack wanted to do this with chick Jack
hmm still got some some some counterplay
not there not much but there is
something if 694 this kind of things hmm
c1 no not yet discovered it's covered I
know I can Jack get this in checkmate
yeah interesting position out of the
opening maybe maybe here he should take
the time to play h3 sometimes a good
idea to prevent Bishop g4 okay i might
have this one I don't think that this
can be great for wide in any case but
why shouldn't be worse i believe here 94
maybe maybe i can even grab here you
have the compass materialistic as usual
and wants to play this yeah why not
actually its server the tempo only three
I didn't really consider that check
yeah what White has some compensation in
form of the bishop am probably not
enough but yeah prolly should have taken
whether this is not not bad yeah 94 is
again the comp choice but i didn't want
to to make it play that easy i mean i
thought and i saw this this kind of line
and I thought well okay it should be
okay for me but it's also nothing great
but it's just a poor now it's okay yeah
maybe I should do that this is this is
not not bad at all but it's you can grab
a pawn you could probably do it yeah
here black is just an excellent shape I
probably made some inaccurate moves
maybe I should take here and then 97 and
not this immediately this really helped
him with it yeah seems that here f3 is
in fact better what is the big prior can
adjust take okay he gave away the pawn
yeah here i'm just really a porn up i
guess unless there is some some trick
bishop tifa what is the problem with
this rook e1 with equality this is easy
for the comp who can takes and then what
is the way is the quality the counter
play may be here with is strong maybe
but it's two pawns comp gives us a
sequel so probably it see some sort of
draw like a perpetual or something yeah
why definitely has played
with this oops with this idea to deform
interesting yeah it was seven it was a
little a little time jack tells a shoe
and here like should win maybe I allowed
something here but in general it is a
win okay thanks for watching